Hello there, sweet internet, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the The Slow Mo Guys.
Dan, what's this bowl about?
It's a Chinese Sprouting bowl.
Its sole purpose is to make
water jump out everywhere.
That's it.
A very purpose-built bowl.
Yeah, that's it.
We saw a GIF of this, online,
where water's leaping out,
and we thought that'd look
fantastic in slow motion.
Talked about getting it, for the show
and Dan was like,
"I like the idea of this bowl so much,
"I'm going to buy it with my own money."
Yeah, I'm taking it home in my suitcase.
You own this bowl.
Yeah, it's mine.
This is your bowl.
Yeah.
So what are you going to
do with it when we're done?
You gonna put potpourri
in it or something?
I guess so or just let people
rub it occasionally when they come in.
Well hopefully this video
resonates well with the audience.
Oh sounds good to me.
Can't bowl-lieve it.
That was a stretch.
Oh, wow.
Whoa.
Pretty, huh?
That's cool.
Can you get it to resonate
in different spots
or is it always from those four corners?
It always goes from these four corners,
but you can get it to do
different patterns, like...
Look how the waves go there, like that.
Sounds like it's...
So if you did it from this side,
Ah, that is so loud!
it only does it from here.
You see the little patterns it does there?
Oh, my hands are in the shadow there.
Makes like a really fine pattern.
We'll get both.
That's really annoying.
It is, stop doing it, ah.
Arg!
See why I wanted to take it home?
So I could annoy people.
Okay.
♪ Intergalactic planetary. ♪
Okay, try one and let
me know when it's good.
Okay.
Takes a minute to build up so.
Yeah.
This channel is going to give you
the oddest set of skills.
Oh, weird it,
from the bowl pushes
out, like, a weird effect
and then is starts rising up from there.
Really cool.
You can see the whole thing jostling.
Wow, that's cool.
The whole bowl is going.
Oh yeah, wow.
Woooaaaah.
That's wicked.
I couldn't see any of that
movement in real life.
No.
I guess I was distracted by the water,
but the whole bowl is
like, "wub, wub, wub, wub".
In real life.
In real time.
It takes ages to get it going,
but when it's going it just goes crazy.
Whoa, look at the bowl wibbling!
It's like a giant speaker.
Yeah.
I like how perfectly it's been designed.
Yeah, they knew what they were doing,
making this thing.
That's nice.
That's gone flying, some
of them just get launched.
Yeah, some are like,
"We'll just hit each other"
some are like, "See ya".
Yeah.
That's the kind of stuff
you can just look at all day innit.
That's wicked.
Like a screensaver.
Whoa, oh wow.
Yeah, you can see
where the movement of the water starts.
I didn't actually--
All the way
up in the handle.
It's like your hand is moving smoothly
but the handle is gripping and letting go
and gripping, letting go, causing
the bowl to move that way.
'Cause it's such a high frequency.
Yeah.
The only way you would be able to see it
is in slow motion, obviously.
But I just thought 'cause it
was a single squeaking sound
you'd never be able to see it.
Well I think I could
watch slow mo globules
collide all day.
Luckily this is an absolute
glob factory, very good.
It is indeed
a glob factory.
Yep.
It's also quiet scientifically interesting
with the way the globs come up
with the bowl resonating.
Yeah the frequency of the bowl
and the way that, I guess,
the waves come from your hands
at these different points
cause it to come up in
four different locations
in a round bowl.
Really strange, yeah.
Like one of those tables you get,
where you take the bow to it
and it makes the patterns in the sand.
It's just like that.
Do you remember the tuning
fork video that we did
where we showed the globs coming up
from either side of that.
Yeah.
This is like that, on
steroids, its just really--
So you're happy with your purchase.
I think you're jealous, you want one.
I would want one, yeah.
I'd probably want it
to be automatic though.
Yeah, of course, yeah.
Just, sort of like, voice activated, like,
"Alexa make the Chinese
bowl make the globs".
And then it's like "bvvv, bvvv, bvvv".
Mug.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
That's loud, I'm distracted.
We have a channel, it's this one.
We also have a second
channel for behind the scenes
and we will see you in the next video.
I'm getting soaked so I'm gonna...
I bet that's annoying.
Oh yeah, I'm gonna annoy
the neighbors with this.
Oh!